المجاوره مشاهدينا الاوضاع اكثر ماساويه
بسبب مشكله وجود ملايين النازحين
واللاجئين السوريين على حدود تركيا نتيجه
الحرب ارقام البصل السوري لحقوق الانسان
تشير الى ارتفاع حصيره قتل الزلزال في
سوريا الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه وثمانيه
افاد من جهته بان نحو 300
نقلوا بل نقلت من تركيا الى الاراضي
السوريه عبر باب الهوى الامم المتحده كشفت
ان عمليات البحث والانقاذ لا تغطي سوى 5%
من المناطق المتضرره بالشمال السوري بينما
قالت منظمه القوه البيضاء ان عدد ضحايا
زلزال سوريا سيرتفع بشكل كبير بسبب وجود
مئات العائلات تحت الانقاض منظمه الاخوه
البيضاء مشاهدينا اضافت ايضا ان عدد
الابنيه المنهاره جزئيا
في غرب سوريا وصل لاكثر من شمال غرب سوريا
وصل اكثر من
1300 من جهته اعلن رئيس وزراء السوري حلب
ولاذقيه اكثر المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال
مؤكدا ان الاولويه لانقاذ من يزالون تحت
الانقاض في هاتين المدينتين